Rhymes and Elon Musk welcomed their
first child on Monday uh you know I
posted a photo with the little guy with
the weird face tattoo thing that was one
of the pictures don't worry the baby is
happy and healthy and cute as a button
now the name is okay here goes it's X
and then the AE symbol which I believe
is pronounced ash a - twelve Musk okay
so that yeah yeah so people are trying
to figure out how to pronounce it and
just trying to make sense of it in
general so grimes tweeted last night
explaining each part so here we go so
yeah so X is the unknown variable so a
he what she is saying is my eleven
spelling of a I so love and or
artificial intelligence a twelve here we
go the precursor to SR seventeen our
favorite aircraft no weapons no defenses
just speed great and battle but
nonviolent plus a also represents her
favorite song arch angel okay now did
respond to this week correcting one part
what he said was that the aircraft is
actually called the sr-71 not the s Mar
17 2014 2 Mike I don't even know so yeah
so I guess you say it so a twelve okay
that the problem is this is that I
understand giving a meaning behind the
name that's fine but you can't send out
a tweet like runs did giving the meaning
behind it without telling us how to
pronounce it right right right like that
that's the one problem then also too so
like there's no way they're gonna say
his name like that every time so where
do you cut it off just call Mike say I
so so what a problem it'll mean yeah
what a lot of people have been saying
yesterday was that the AE symbol is
actually pronounced as ash it's the ash
symbol and then you say I yes I know but
this has been one of the theories
yesterday was that
could be pronounced if you go X and then
ashen and ah it could be Sasha is what
the one one of the ways you could
radically theoretically pronounce if you
strung all those legs together which I
don't know I don't know why you would do
this it's it's not I don't know it's not
a name it's like it's a car part number
right right right like Leslie says that
poor kid wait till he gets the middle
school
Valeska says such a pretentious name
Paula says certain easy to get microchip
to like I also wonder like could this be
almost like they're like gas lighting
like the public and they're really gonna
call him like Steve in private like
whether there's like that they're
trolling us yeah I don't know yeah
especially because you know it was Elon
Musk who released what the name was and
presumably Grimes was still sort of
dealing with everything that a woman has
to deal with after childbirth so maybe
he just threw this out and now he's just
dealing with his troll right Paula says
imagine saying that name in a romantic
moment Kelly says it's certainly unique
well I mean we've heard some unique
celebrity names over the years but this
definitely takes the cake yeah I've
never heard a celebrity name or any name
that has 8 - 12 in it I'm psychic symbol